so thanks a lot Peter for joining me
today um I think a lot of people know
you as a well known machine learning and
deep learning and robotics researcher
like to have people here but about your
story how did you end up doing the work
that you do yeah it's a it's a good
question and actually if you would have
asked me as a as a 14 year old what I
was aspiring to do it probably would not
have been this in fact at the time I
thought being a professional basketball
player would be the right way to go I
don't think I was able to achieve it I
feel that machine let me left out that
DeVos ball didn't work out yeah that
didn't work out it was a lot of fun
playing basketball but it didn't work
out to try to make it into a career
so what I really liked in school was
physics and math and so from there it
seemed pretty natural to study
engineering which is applying physics
and math in the real world and I should
them after my undergrad in electrical
engineering a she wasn't so sure what
the Duke is which we anything
engineering seemed interesting to me
like understanding how anything works
seems interesting trying to build
anything is interesting and in some
sense artificial intelligence went out
because it seemed like it could somehow
help all disciplines in some way and
also it seems somehow
a little more at the core of everything
like you think about how a machine can
think then maybe that's more the core of
everything else than picking any
specific discipline and saying you know
a is the new electricity sounds like the
fourteen-year-old here's know if you had
an earlier version of that event you
know in the past few years you've done a
lot of work in deep reinforcement
learning what's happening why is deeper
enforcement learning suddenly taking off
before I worked in deep reinforcement
learning and I work a lot in
reinforcement learning actually with you
and ER at Stanford of course and so we
worked on autonomous helicopter flight
then later at Berkeley with some of my
students who worked on getting a robot
to learn to fall laundry and kind of
what characterized the work was a
combination of learning that enabled
things that would not be possible
without learning but also a lot of
domain expertise in
with the learning to get this to work
and it it was very interesting because
you needed the main expertise which is
fun to acquire but at the same time was
very time-consuming for every new
application you wanted to succeed you
need domain expertise plus machine
learning expertise and for me was in
2012 with the imagenet breakthrough
results from Jeff Hinton's group in
Toronto
Alex Ned showing that supervised
learning all of a sudden could be done
with far less engineering for the domain
at hand there was very low engineering
by a vision in Alex net made me think we
really should revisit reinforcement
learning under the same kind of
viewpoint and see if we can get the deep
version of reinforcement learning to
work and do equally interesting things
as had just happened in the supervised
learning and so you know sounds like you
saw earlier than most people the
potential of deeper enforcement of
learning so now looking into the future
what do you see next what your
prediction so that makes several ways to
come in deeper also learning so I think
what's interesting about deep
reinforcement learning is down in some
soon as there is many more questions
none in supervised learning in
supervised learning is about learning an
input-output mapping with reinforcement
learning there is the notion of where
does the data even come from so that's
the exploration problem when you have
data how do you do credit assignment how
do you understand what actions you took
early on got you the reward later and
then there's issues of safety when you
have a system of times like collecting
data essentially rather dangerous in
most situations imagine the self-driving
car company that says we're just gonna
run deep reinforcement learning it's
pretty likely that car will get into a
lot of accidents before it does anything
useful
you need two negative examples of those
oh right you do need some negative
examples somehow yeah send positive ones
hopefully so I think there's still a lot
of challenges in deep reinforcement
learning in terms of working out some of
the specifics of how to get these things
to work so the deep part is the
representation within the reinforcement
learning itself still has a lot of
questions and what I feel is that with
the advanced advances in deep learning
somehow one part of the puzzle in
reinforcement learning has been largely
addressed which is the representation
part so if
if there is a pattern we can probably
represent it with a deep network and
capture that pattern and then how that
tease apart the pattern is still a big
challenge in reinforcement learning so I
think big challenges are how to get
systems to reason over long time
horizons so right now a lot of the
successes in deep reinforcement learning
are very short horizon there are
problems where if you act well over a
five second horizon you act well over
the entire problem and so a five second
skill was something very different from
a day-long skill or the ability to live
a life as a robot or some software agent
so I think there's a lot of challenges
there I think safety has a lot of
challenges in terms of how do you learn
learn safely and also how do you keep
learning once you're already pretty good
so give an example again that a lot of
people would be familiar with
self-driving cars for a self-driving car
to be better than a human driver I
should that human drivers may begin to
accidents bad accidents every three
million miles or something and so that
takes a long time to see the negative
data once you're as good as a human
driver but you want your cell down in
car to be better than a human driver and
so at that point the data collection
becomes really really difficult to get
that interesting data that makes your
system improve there's a lot of
challenges related to exploration that
tie into that but one of the things I'm
actually most excited about right now is
seeing if we can actually take a step
back and also learn the reinforcement
learning algorithm so reinforcement is
very complex credits and very complex
explorations very complex and so maybe
just like how deep learning for
supervised learning was able to replace
a lot of domain expertise maybe we can
have programs that are learned that are
reinforcement learning programs and the
do all this instead of us designing the
details the river-water functional
during the whole program so this would
be learning the entire reinforcement
learning program so it would be imagine
you have a reinforcement learning
program whatever it is and you you throw
it out some problem and then you see how
long it takes to learn and then you say
well that took a while now let another
program modify this ring for
learning program after the modification
see how fast it learns if it learns more
quickly that was a good modification and
maybe you keep it and improve from there
Wow I see right yeah this is direction
yeah it's I think it's a lot to do with
maybe the amount of compute that's
becoming available so the more this
would be running reinforcement learning
in the inner loop whereas right now we
were unreinforced millenials the final
thing and so the more compute we get the
more it becomes possible to maybe run
something like reinforcement learning in
the inner loop of a bigger algorithm so
you know starting from the 14 euro you
you've worked in the iPhone maybe what
some 20-plus years now so so tell me a
bit about how your understanding of AI
has evolved over this at this time yeah
so when I started looking at AI sorry
interesting cuz it really coincided with
coming to Stanford to do my master's
degree there and there were some icons
there like John McCarthy who I got to
talk with but who had a very different
approach to and in the year 2004 what
most people are doing at the time but
also talking with Daphne Koller and I
think a lot of my initial thinking of AI
was shaped by Daphne's thinking her AI
class her brow was the graphical models
class and kind of really being intrigued
by how simply a distribution over many
random variables and then being able to
condition on some subsets of variables
and throwing conclusions about others
could actually give you so much if you
can somehow make it computationally
intractable which was definitely the
challenge to make it computable and then
from there when I start my PhD and her
you you arrived at Stanford and I think
you gave me a really good reality check
that's that's not the right metric to
evaluate your your work by and to really
try to see the the connection from what
you're working on to what impact it can
can really have what change it can make
rather than what's the math that
happened to to be in your work right
this doesn't mean I I
that I did not realize that we got
through that yeah it's actually one of
the things that most often to people
people asking them once if you're gonna
cite only one thing that has stuck with
you from Andrews advice it's it's making
sure you can see the connection to where
it's actually gonna do something um you
know you've had and you're continuing to
have an amazing career in AI so for some
of the people you know listening to you
on video now if they want to also enter
or pursue a career in AI what what
advice do you have for them I think it's
a really good time to get into
artificial intelligence it's if you look
at the demand for for people it's so
high there is so many so many job
opportunities so many things you can do
research wise build new companies and so
forth so I would say yes it's definitely
a smart decision in terms of actually
getting going a lot of it you can self
study whether you're in school or not
there is a lot of online courses in your
machine learning course there is also
for example
Andrea Kerr posses deep learning course
which has videos online which is a great
way to get started at Berklee do is a
deep reinforced learning course which is
all the lectures online so those are all
good places to get started I think a big
part of what what's important is to to
make sure you try things yourself
so not just read things or and watch
videos but try things out with
frameworks like tensorflow chainer
Theano
pi torch and so forth and then whatever
is your favorite just it's very easy to
get going and get something up and
running very quickly to get the practice
yourself very good implementing and see
what works and see what doesn't work so
this past week there was an article in
Mashable about a 16 year old and United
Kingdom who is one of the leaders on
Carroll competitions and he just said he
just went out and learn things found
things online learned everything himself
and never actually took any formal
course per se and there is a 16 year old
just being very competitive in Carroll
competitions so it's definitely possible
yeah we live in good times very people
that one has learned absolutely one
question I bet you get all sometimes is
if someone wants to you know enter AI
machine learning deep learning should
they apply for a ph.d program or should
they get the job as big company I think
a lot of it has to do with maybe how
much mentoring you can get so in a ph.d
program you're essentially guaranteed
the job of the professor is who is your
advisor is to look out for you try to do
everything they can to kind of shape you
help you become stronger at whatever you
want to do for example AI and so there's
a very clear dedicated person sometimes
you have to advise it and that's that's
literally a job and that's why they are
professors that's most of what they like
about being professors often is helping
shape students to become more capable at
things now it doesn't mean it's not
possible at companies and many companies
have really good mentors and have people
who love to help educate people who come
in and strengthen them in so forth it's
just it might not be as much of a
guarantee and a given compared to
actually enrolling in a ph.d program
where that's the crux of the program is
that you're gonna learn and somebody is
there to help you learn yes so it really
depends on the company and depends on
the ph.d program absolutely yeah but I
think it is key that then you can learn
a lot on your own but I think you can
learn a lot faster if you have somebody
who's more experienced to is actually
taking it up as their responsibility to
spend time with you and help accelerate
your progress so you know you've been
one of the most visible leaders in deep
reinforcement learning so what are the
things that deep reinforcement learning
is already working really well at I
think if you look at some deep reinforce
learning successes it's it's very very
intriguing for example learning to play
Atari games from pixels processing this
pixels which is just numbers that are
being processed somehow and turning to
joystick actions then for example some
of the work we did at Berkeley where we
have a simulated robot inventing walking
and the reward that it's given is as
simple as the further you go north the
better and the less hard you impact with
the ground the better and somehow it
decides that walking / running is the
thing to invent whereas nobody showed it
while walking is or running is or robot
playing with children
poison learned to kind of put them
together put a block into a matching
opening and so forth and so I think I
think it's really just alert from raw
sensory inputs all the way to raw
controls for example torques at the
motors but at the same time so it's very
interesting that you can have a single
algorithm for example no trustees and
policy items is you can learn can have a
robot learn to run can ever robot learn
to stand up can have instead of a two
legged robot now you're swapping a
four-legged robot you run the same
reinforce learning algorithm and it
still learns to run and so there's no
changing the reinforcement algorithm
it's very very general same for the
Atari games dqn was the same dqn for
every one of the games but then when it
actually starts hitting the frontiers of
what's not yet possible as well it's
it's it's nice it learns from scratch
for each one of these tasks but it would
be even nicer if it could reuse things
that's learned in the past to learn even
more quickly for the next task and
that's something that that's still at
the frontier and not yet possible it
always starts from scratch essentially
how quickly do you think you see deeper
for learning get deployed in the robots
around us or the robots in you know
they're getting deployed in it well
today I think in practice the realistic
scenario is one where it's it starts
with supervised learning behavioral
cloning humans do them do the work and I
think actually a lot of businesses will
be built that way where it's a human
behind the scenes doing a lot of the
work
imagine facebook messenger assistant a
system like that could be built with a
human behind the curtains doing a lot of
the work machine learning matches up
with what the human does and starts
making suggestions to the humans sodium
has a small number of options available
you can just to click and select and
then over time as it gets pretty good
you start infusing some reinforcement
learning where you give it actual
objectives not just matching the human
behind the curtains but give it
objectives of achievement like maybe how
fast were these two people able to plan
their their meeting or how fast were
they able to book their flight or things
like that how long did it take how happy
were they with it but it would probably
be bootstrapped
of a lot of behavioral cloning of humans
showing
how this could be done so saw the
behavioral clothing just supervised
learning to mimic whatever the person is
doing and then gradually layer on the
reinforcement learning to have it think
about longer time horizons is that a
fair summary I'd say so yeah just
because straight up reinforcement
learning from scratch is is really fun
to watch it's it's super intriguing and
very few things more fun to watch than a
reinforced learning robot starting from
nothing and inventing things but it's
just time consuming and it's not always
safe thank you very much that was
fascinating but I'm really glad we had
the chance to chat well and ER thank you
for having me
very much appreciate it